well drinking coffee has become a very  special trend here in the las vegas  valley and although you can make it at  home  more people are choosing coffee shops  for a special experience nikolai koralev  is a trainer for bad  owl coffee roasters and he tells us  although there are multiple locations  this rainbow location in the southwest  is the heart of all of them due to their  roasting room there now aside from that  they sell pastries and sandwiches  it wasn't really intentional it's just  when the owners opened their first  location  they were liking some decorations so  they brought decorations from their own  house  and they were fans of harry potter  well their coffee is so popular that  even some people from out of state  are ordering it online and then of  course they get it shipped  to them so if i worked at a coffee place  i wouldn't stop drinking coffee that's  that'd be the problem but i'd be highly  caffeinated